One of the things that was suggested during
the first presidential debate by Donald Trump
was that Trump suggested his supporters go
to the polls and observe what's going on,
hang out at polling places, see if things
look okay.
Now, as I mentioned, if you there are poll
workers and there are poll volunteers, you
can't just show up and volunteer on the day
off.
You have to actually sign up to do that.
If you just show up and you're, quote, observing
and you're you're essentially loitering in
some states, that's against the law and it's
voter intimidation.
And Nevada's attorney general is not taking
this lightly and has said if you do what Trump
is suggesting, we will arrest you and we will
prosecute you because it is in Nevada illegal.
Let's start with a reminder about what Donald
Trump said about this Tuesday night at the
debate.
So I first for you, sir.
Finally for for the vice president.
I hope neither of you will interrupt the other.
Will you urge your supporters to stay calm
during this extended period, not to engage
in any civil unrest?
And will you pledge tonight that you will
not declare victory until the election has
been independently certified?
President Trump, I about watching my supporters
to go into the polls and watch very carefully,
because that's what has to happen.
I am urging them to do it.
As you know, today, there was a big problem
in Philadelphia.
They went in to watch.
They were called poll watchers, a very safe,
very nice thing.
They were thrown out.
They weren't allowed to watch.
You know why?
Because bad things happen in Philadelphia.
Bad things.
So the reason Trump's poll watchers were thrown
out is that they weren't actually poll watchers.
There is a process.
If you want to be a volunteer, you have to
actually sign up.
Typically, it's run at the county level.
But you'd have to see how it is in your your
city, state or municipality.
You don't just show up or show up armed as
someone who is there to observe the way Donald
Trump is suggesting it's not going to do.
It's voter intimidation to hang out all day
at polls without being an actual volunteer
who signed up and is on a list of someone
who's going to be there to do that.
And Trump is encouraging that.
Trump is encouraging voter intimidation and
it shouldn't surprise us.
Trump encouraged try to vote twice.
That's a felony in some places, including
North Carolina.
Trump has encouraged all sorts of behavior
that is either immoral or illegal in some
cases.
And Nevada's attorney general says we will
prosecute people who do this.
If you do this, we will prosecute, prosecute
you.
If you follow Donald Trump's advice and you
go to polling places and you monitor votes
being cast or counted, it is voter intimidation.
Aaron Ford tweeted, quote, Trump also told
his supporters to go into the polls and watch
very carefully.
But he wasn't talking about poll watching.
He was talking about voter intimidation.
For your information, voter intimidation is
illegal in Nevada.
Believe me when I say it, you do it and you
will be prosecuted.
Now, to follow up on Trump's claim that some
injustice has transpired because his fans
who showed up in Philly weren't allowed in.
We looked into it.
Legitimate poll officers and volunteers in
Philadelphia have been able to do their jobs.
But you have to actually be there in an official
capacity.
Random people who show up and say I'm going
to watch aren't actually part of anything.
They can't hang out intimidating people.
That's not.
I was going to say it's not how our democracy
works.
It's not how our democracy is supposed to
work.
Now, for you, what to do if you see funny
business when you go to vote?
Three things to keep in mind.
Number one, you can report voter intimidation
to the ACLU by calling 866 our vote.
Put it in your phone.
Number two, you can report voter intimidation
or electioneering or whatever to the local
county elections board.
Again, most elections are run at the county
level.
That's why we get results county by county,
often on election night.
Google the phone number for your county elections
board.
Put it in your phone before you go.
You can.
Safe.
If you can safely and legally get video of
what's going on.
Send it to me.
I will do everything I can to send it to my
media contacts and to publicize it on this
program.
This applies to early voting.
This applies on Election Day.
We will be standing by on Election Day to
hear from you if funny business is going on.
It's also important for people to know what
is and is not permitted in their jurisdiction.
So there's a brief summary of poll watcher
laws available.
We're linking to a Web site that has that
summary in the description to this YouTube
clip.
So you've got already you can just Google
a poll watcher laws, Massachusetts, poll watcher
laws, Louisiana or whatever state you live
in.
So, like as an example, in New York, each
party can have three poll watchers present
and the poll watchers can challenge your right
to vote when you appear at the polling place.
But it would not override any anti-discrimination
laws if they're challenging every black voter
or disproportionately black voters.
That wouldn't be OK.
You know, enforcing it in the heat of Election
Day is another question.
It also never permits harassment, intimidation,
coercion, electioneering, trying to either
prevent someone from voting or influencing
vote.
So that's New York.
Understand the laws in your state.
And, yeah, it's tragic that this is how we
have to prepare to go and vote.
My plan for now is I do have an absentee ballot
coming.
And if it gets to me reasonably soon, I don't
know when Massachusetts is sending them out.
I would fill it out and drop it off personally.
Otherwise, I might avail myself of the early
voting that takes place in Massachusetts.
That's my thought.
Let me know your plan.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
And remember that if you prefer a long form
audio podcast each day, rather than short
YouTube clips or Facebook video clips, you
can find our audio podcast just about on any
podcast, platform I, iTunes, Stitcher, Spotify,
so on and so forth.
Find us there.
Let me know your voting plan on Twitter at
David Pakman.
And we will be right back.